[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه الكرام اليسا طبيعيا انت نهار
العملات العربيه تباع في بلاد يحكمها
اللصوص وعصابات العسكر والمفيات الطائفيه
والامنيه وتجار الحروب والازمات كيف تنهض
الليره
المخدرات وابتزاز رجال الاعمال
والاقتصاديين و تهجير الشعب والقوى
العامله ورؤوس الاموال وتحويل الناس الى
ثله من الجائعين والمعدمين كيف تزدهر
العمله في بلاد يحكمها العسكر ورجالات
المخابرات الذين يفهمون بالاقتصاد كما
افهم انا بالانشطار النووي
كيف تزدهر العمله في بلاد تحكمها عصابات
طائفيه لا هم لها سوى نهب البلاد وافكار
العباد اليس تدهور العملات المحليه في
العديد من البلدان العربيه نتيجه طبيعيه
للثورات المضاده التي نجحت في اعاده
الشعوب الى زريبه الطاعه لكنها فشلت في
تامين الخبز والنهوض بالاقتصادات
لكن في المقابل اليس هناك عوامل خارجيه
ادت الى تدهور حتى العملات الاوروبيه
القويه اليس طبيعيه ان تنهار الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه والعمولات والمحليه
في بلاد مرت على مدى عقد الماضي بتحولات
واضطرابات سياسيه واجتماعيه طاحنه اليس من
الطبيعي اي ينخفض سعر العمله الى الحضيض
في دول توقفت فيها حركه الانتاج بسبب
الحروب والتدخل الخارجي كسوريا واليمن
وليبيا والعراق ولبنان والسودان الا تبقى
بعض العملات العربيه المترنحه اقوى بكثير
من عمولات بلاد لم تشهد ربعها ما شهدته
بلداننا من مصائب وكوارث الا يمر العالم
اجمع اليوم باضطرابات الماليه واقتصاديه
تهز الكبار قبل الصغار
اسئله اطرحها على الدكتور رائد المصري
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
الاقتصاديه وعلى الدكتور عبد النبي عبد
المطلب وكيل وزاره الاقتصاد المصري السابق
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
الكلام نحن معكم في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس دكتور رائد معك ما الذي يحدث
لا هم للشعوب العربيه في العديد من
البلدان سواء التي مرت فيما يسمى بالربيع
العربي او حتى لم تمر لم يعد هناك حديث
للشعوب سوى وضع العملات المحليه انهيار
العملات المحليه وما يرافق ذلك من جنون في
الاسعار واا يعني ظروف معيشيه كارثيه لم
تعد تستثني احدا سوا دول الوفره وانت تعلم
في الخليج العربي ما الذي يحدث
هذه النظم الحاكمه في المنطقه همم في
الدول العربيه المشار اليها يعني المعروف
السودان ومصر تونس وهمم سوريا
متفرد في الحكم يعتبر ان الناس والشعوب هي
مجرد ارقام هو يتعاطى معها مقاومته يعني
على على يتعاطى معها ولا يرسم لها مستقبل
وبالتالي
رهن كل المقدرات الدوله للخارج ارتباطات
بالخارج كان من مشاريع سياسيه او كان
مشاريع اقتصاديه معلوم انا انهيارات
العملات معروف هو الاداء الاقتصادي والعجز
الاقتصادي الذي يؤدي الى التضخم معروف انه
سوء الائتمان لدى القروض وبنعرف نحن
القروض التجديد على القروض في البنوك هذا
يعطي ايضا يعني اشاره سلبيه همم ضعف
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للدوله ضعف القوه
الشرائيه لدى الفرد التدخل او الانقسامات
الحاده داخل الدوله والحروب الداخليه
وايضا الحروب الخارجيه التي تفتعلها او
يفتعلها النظام الحاكم او الحكام النظام
الحكم طبعا مش الشعوب الشعوب يعني هي
الشعوب راقيه تريد ان تعيش تريد ان تحيا
تريد ان تؤمن مستقبلها لكن هؤلاء الطغاه
المستحكمين في العباد تاره بحجه وشعار
تحرير فلسطين
فورا بالحجه الدينيه والفتاوى الدينيه
اخرى بالمفهوم القومي القومي بين مزدوجان
والتحشيد القومي والتعبئه القوميه
الاقتصاديه وغيرها والناس لا زالت الى
اليوم تحت الجوع والفقر هذه الدول ليوم
الناس تاكل من حاويه الزباله اليوم الناس
لا تستطيع ليس لديها خبز ليس يعني في دول
عنا بالمنطقه يعني سوريا ولبنان والعراق
وغير يعني ما في كهرباء من 15 عامه في
كهرباء ليس لدينا كهرباء في هذه المنطقه
عن اي مشاريع سياسيه تتحدث هذه الطغم
الحاكمه هذا النظام الاستبدادي هؤلاء
المتفلسفون الذين يجلسون على الكراسي
الذين يتقاتلون في لبنان لم يتقاتلون ولا
بواخر يدفعون ضرائبها اليوم في الميناء
اللبناني ولا ينضون مش عم يمضوا على وراء
حتى يجيبوا كهرباء من اللبنانيين انت
ماروني وانا سني وهذاك شيء وانا ما بمضي
وانت محاكيني بدها مستقبل وبدها تبني
مستقبل لاجيال هؤلاء مصيرهم حاويات
الزباله هؤلاء مصيرهم السجون ان اقلش
الاعدامات
بطبيعه الحال يعني مش معقول الشعوب تعبت
ان احنا تعبنا كل الشعوب العربيه تعبت من
هذه الطعم الحاكمه تعبت من هذه الشعارات
الفضفاضه هذه الشعارات الفارغه هذه الخوف
الشاميات هذه اخذ الشعوب الى الى حروب
خارجيه والى استقطبات حاده داخليه وطائفيه
ومذهبيه وبعدين بالمناسبه تسريح
الميليشيات يعني هناك قوه ميداسيويه في كل
هذه الدول تضغط على قوه الدوله وسياده
الدوله وسياده الجيش يعني هذا معروف صار
بكلها هذه الدول صارت سما تلجا اليها هذه
النظم وهذه الاحزاب الطائفيه والمنسيه ليش
هيك ما هو الهدف من وراء ذلك حتى تمنع اي
حراك تغييره اي حراك شعبي اي حراك يريد
الاصلاح ويريد بناء مستقبله تلجا الى هذه
المستوى الى هذه الميليشيات المنظمه هل
تعلم يا سيدي انه في لبنان في 15,000 موظف
في وزارات الدوله لا يداومون ويقبضون من
وزاره الخزانه اللبنانيه ما بيداومون بس
ان تابعين لا زعماء حتى اذا صار اي حراك
التغيير بينزلوا على الشارع وبيقتلوا
الناس هاتوها وبيطلعوا من ثم الى الى الى
الى الزعيم يلجئون الى الزعيم هذا هو
الواقع الحاكم كامليشيا في لبنان وفي
سوريا وفي العراق وفي اليمن وفي كل هذه
البلدان هل بهذه الدول امر طبيعي ان تكون
هذه العملات في هذا الانهيار امر طبيعي
وما حدا يتحجج ويقول الامريكي والمشروع
الغربي ومدري شو انتم صنعتم في هذه الدول
وفي هذه الشعوب هذا الانحدار وهذا الدرك
الاسفل لقضايا الشعوب واللجوعها وليعطشها
ولي ولي هل تعلم انه اليوم اصلا ما في
مدارس في هذه هدوء ما في مدارس يبقى اذا
ما في مدارس ما في خالص ما في كهرباء ما
في انترنت انت شو بعدك حاكم شيش شعارات
الماسك فيها لماذا انتم ما زلتم على
كراسيكم ما عم نفهم انا حتى انا جاوب كل
هذه لكل العالم لكل الشعوب ليش ما تكون
على كراسيكم اذا انا ما ادرا نجيب كهربا
اصل انا ما اقدر من الخبز هل تعرف انه في
لبنان ما في حبه بنادول في كل الاسواق
واليوم يتغنون بالشعارات ويطلعوا يعني
بتبجحون انت مسيحي وانا سني وانا شيعي
وانا صلاحيتي انت على شو عم تتقاتلوا هل
هذه النقب حاكمه تستطيع ان تواجه المشاريع
الخارجيه لا الطبيعي ومن الطبيعي ان تكون
هذه العملات منهاره بهذا الشكل وستبقى
كذلك ما لم يتم حسبه هؤلاء الفاسدين
وهؤلاء الطغات والاستبدادين الذين قتلوا
الناس باكثر من شكر جميل جدا دكتور كيف
ترد
جزء مهم جدا ان بالفعل الفساد في الدول
العربيه احد اهم الاسباب التي ادت الى
نهايه الاقتصادي لكن علينا ان نعلم جميعا
ان هذا الانهيار هو خلال العقدين الماضيين
العقدين الماضيين شاهدت فيهم المنطقه
العربيه والكل يعلم ما يسمى بالربيع
العربي صحيح نحن كنا نتمنى الخير وننتظر
الخير لكن واضح ان الشعوب لم تتمكن من
المداومه على الاستمرار في مشروعها القومي
من اجل الوصول الى حياه كارمه يعني سؤال
مهم جدا قالوا الدكتور الرائد الناس تاكل
من من من من القمامه السؤال من اين يحصلون
على ما يقتلون به من القمامه اليس هناك
وفره عند البعض ولذلك يلقون ببعض ما لديهم
في القمه ومن هنا بدلا من ان يتحرك
الانسان او يعمل او يحاول ان يزيد من
داخله او من حياته لا هو يستسهل للاسف في
شديد في المنطقه العربيه يريدون حياه
الاكل من القمامه مقابل امان زائف للاسف
الشديد يعني مشكله شعوب مشكله شعوب جزء
اخر بالتاكيد جميعها يعني المساله على
الشعوب يعني هذا كلام هذا كلام في افتئات
كثير كبيره
بس خليني
يعني
هذه العملات انهيار العملات لا تتحدث لي
عن ايه اسباب سوى هذه النظم الحاكمه التي
يعني عبثت بالاقتصاد وعبثت بالمال وعبثت
بالثروات وعبثت بلقمه العيش وعبثت
بالكهرباء وكل شيء الاشكال يا دكتور همم
فيصل والدكتور رائد مؤكد يعلم ذلك ان هناك
بعض النظريات التي تتحدث عن ان تخفيض قيمه
العمله هو محاوله لجعل الاقتصاد اكثر
تنافسيه يعني عندما نتحدث عن تركيا تركيا
ما زاله هناك انهيار موجود في الليره
انهيار من يعني الدولار من 12 الى 18 ليره
19 تقريبا ليره حتى اذا تحدثنا عن اليورو
الذي كان واحد يورو بيساوي واحد فاصل خمسه
دولار الان نتحدث في فتره من الفترات كان
يعني
كسر اليورو في فتره من الفترات امام
الدولار وكان اقل من دولار يعني بعض للاسف
دي بعض النظريات تقول ان تخفيض قيم العمله
همم يؤدي الى وجود تنفسيه في الاقتص من
هنا بعد بعض النقاب تحاول ان تنفذ هذه
التوصيه ولها مرجعيه اقتصاديه لكن لكن يجب
ان يكون ذلك من خلال وجود شعبي حقيقي يضمن
عدم المساس بمصالح الشعوب للاسف الشديد
هذا غير موجود يعني الدكتور التحدث عن عدم
وجود كهرباء في لبنان ربما في سوريا ربما
في سوريا انا اتفهم الامر في سوريا ال-
ال- ال- ال- ال- الحكم اليد الحاكمه قويه
والقبضه قويه الشبيحه البارود المتفجر
يعني كلها امور قد ترعب عدد كبير جدا لكن
في لبنان في لبنان انت تتحدث عن توقف لكل
طائفه لها قوه لها جيشها لها مليشيتها
وكذلك في العراق
عندما نتحدث عن لبنان كيف يقبل المواطن
اللبناني الذي عاش في عاصمه الشرق لم يكن
هناك مكان في الخليج او في حتى في مصر
يريدون ان يكون هناك فعاليه ثقافيه قويه
او كبيره الا وكنت مقصودهم كان بيروت
بيروت كانت كانها عاصمه الثقافه العربيه
وعاصمه الفن العربي كيف قبل اللبنانيين
نقول ان في العراق في سوريا هنالك تغمى
حاكمه لا يستطيع الشعب ان يتحرك لكن في
لبنان لا تعطيني ان الشعب يعني هناك من
يسيطر على مقدرته يمنعه من الحركه الا
التوازنات الطائفيه يعني لا يريد ان يتحرك
للمطالبه للمطالبه يعني باختصار دفاعا عن
عن هذا الوضع ان جزء من هذه التصرفات هو
مقصود وربما مدروس على خلفيه اقتصاديه ان
تخفيض قيمه العمله قد يؤدي الى زياده هذا
الاقتصاد عدم وجود همم منظمات شعبيه
حقيقيه في هذه الدول
بس دكتور يعني دول يعني على الدول العربيه
التي تخفض عمولاتها يعني من اجل التنافسيه
اي تنافسيه ايه ونيله ايه ههه اه ايه
تنفسيه في سوريا ان انهيار العمله في
سوريا
من اجل التنافسيه انهيار العمله في لبنان
خلال فتره قصيره من 1500 ليره الى 50,000
حولها ل 50,000 في مصر الى النصف تقريبا
في العراق في العراق
بدات السياحه العالميه تزيد بمقدار 10% في
مصر ودا يعني شيء لا يدافع عن مصر يعني
لكن من سبتمبر الماضي وحتى الان زادت
ارادات السياحه بملياردو خلي يكمل اتفضل
يعني في بعض الدول في حتى ضربنا مثال في
تركيا اقتصاد كبير واقتصاد ضخمه ولو ومع
ذلك التحفيظ الحادث هو المقصود هناك
مرجعيه اقتصاديه بتقول ان تخفيض قيمه
العملاء يجعل الاقتصاد والمنتجات والمنتجه
في هذا ال- ال- الاقتصاد سواء كانت من
ناحيه السياحه او من ناحيه السياحه اكثر
تنافسيه وبذلك تزيد العملاء
يا دكتور في هل يمكن ان تبتلع مثل هذا
الكلام ابدا ابدا بالمطلق هذا كلام يعني
يعني اسف انه كله خاطئ راح اقول لك ليش
لانه اولا انت متبرر هذا التسلط
والاستبداد من قبل الحكام ثانيا على مستوى
الانهيار العملات او تخفيض العملات هذه
الدول اقتصاداتها الريعيه قائمه على جزء
بسيط من السياحه والتحويلات المغتربين
وبالتالي اي دوله الصين مثلا تلجا الى
تخفيض عملتها من اجل تسهيل همم
الصناعات هاي دول متقدمه عندما تتخذها او
تركيا عندما تتخذ هذا المنحه ال- ال-
الاقتصادي هي بتعرف لو انا رايحه وبعدين
حتى الصين مع ذلك تراقب حركه الدولار
حركه البنك الاحتياطي ال- ال- الفيدرالي
الامريكي واسعار الفائده تبعته على اساسها
هي بتقوم لاحظ لاحظ الصين يعني بيعمل كل
حول بيتحدثوا امريكا وانقسم العالم
والبريكس والمدرسه
راقب حركه تراقب حركه الدولار واسعار
الفائده اذا ارتفحت ام لا وبدات تقيس
اليوان
بتقاوموا على على اساس الدولار فاذا
انخفاض قيمه العملات ما هدفه الاساسي هو
انه نحن بدنا نسهل يمكن من سهل جزء بسيط
بالسياحه كما حصل في تركيا تلجا الى هذا
الموضوع بس في عندك انت نظام التعويم هل
احد يعرف شو هو نظام التعاون يعني بيتركه
للعرض والطلب من السوق وفي ايضا نظام
الغير معاون المعاون كما في دول الخليج
اللي هي الاداره والمصرف المركزي بيمسك
هذه العمله وممنوع انه هي حدا يتجاوزها في
سياسات نقديه واقتصاديه تنتهجها هذه الدول
هي القادره ان تواجه اي ازمه عن بتصير ان
كان على مستوى ثلاثه التوريد والحرب
الروسيه الاخرانيه والنفط والغاز وغيرها
وغيرها بس هذه الدول اليوم في المنطقه
العربيه والتي تعاني من ازمات
لا اعلم مستوى الشعبي ده اولا لانه هي ما
عندها شرعي شعبيه يا اخي هذه النظم ما
عندها شرعيه شعبيه هي كل زعيم رئيس عم
بحكي انا فقط في لبنان كل زعيم بيعتبر
حاله عنده حوالات 20 30 كيفيه ومفلتهم
كذاران وكبيريشيه في المنطقه وبياتي
بالحاله ان هو صاحب نهج اقتصادي
بجوز هذا الكلام
يعني هذه النقطه المهمه جدا سناتي عليها
بس قبل ما ياتي على الشعوب لا خلينا في
هذا الموضوع موضوع انه يمكن ان تستفيد من
تخفيض العمله او تعويم العمله دولنا
بتستفيد لما بتكون هي دول صناعيه هي قادره
انها تصدر يعني هي يعني اهم دوله العراق
او مصر بصدره النفط بصدره الامور
التقليديه او الغاز هنا ما بيعطي يعني ما
بيعوم من الميزانيه الميزانيه بيعومه هو
حركه الاموال همم الاحتياطات النقديه
الاجنبيه في داخل الدوله هل هي موجوده من
هو المستثمر الذي يجرا ان يضع امواله في
مصر لبنان سوريا حتى يستمر معك قوه الدولي
ما هو حجم الناتج المحلي قومي لدى هذه
الدول جيش قوه شراء الفرد امنحاول انا
بعرف الاقتصاد للدولي في هذه الدول التي
تحكمها هؤلاء او يحكمها هؤلاء الطغاه
والمستبدون والفاسدين بعد الفساد يعني
احنا ما بننسى الفساد ما الفساد جزء اساسي
اساسي من انهيار هذه الدول ليش في فساد
وليش ممنوع انه يحاسب الفساد ليش بيعتبره
انه سنوات سنقاتل الشيطان لاكبر امريكا
ولكن الفاسد اللي هو بيدارك ما بتشيله ما
بتشوفه لانه هم ما عندهم استعداد ابدا ان
يفقده ولا ذره من شرعتهم الشعبيه المنتشره
على الفساد لانه لما انت بدك تكون متسلط
بالقوه على الحكم لازم يكون معك انت
مجموعات وزمر منتفعه من الدولي ومن خيرات
الدوله مثل ما قلت لك انا بعدنا لحد هلا
في عندنا من 10 ل 15,000 موظف في الادارات
الحكوميه في الدوله بالاتصالات وبالسياحه
شغلتهم بيعلقوا صور للزعيم ولا زعماء
الطوائف في لبنان وبيقبضوا من الدولي
مع البنك الدولي اذا واطرح استراحات كيف
لبنان وكان في مصر وكان في تونس بكلها هذه
الدول ما يقبلوا معه بهذه الاصلاحات لانه
بدها تشلحهم مكتسباتهم من هؤلاء الناس
اللي هن مهتطينهم على المستوى الشرعي
والشعب وطبعا هي شرعيه وهي وهم كاذبون
ودجلون هم يتحججدون بالشعار لكي يبقوا
تسلطها على الحكم وعلى الناس وعلى العباد
وبي- بمنع الخبز عنها وتحقيق احلامها في
التعليم وفي الامن وفي الصحه لبنان بلد في
سبعه مليون في ثلاثه مليون سوري ليش سوري
في لبنان في 600,000 فلس فلسطيني بدون
كهرباء وما في دواء وما مكشوف صحيا على
كفه المستوى تخيل البلد كامل مكشوف صحيا
ما حدا بيقدر لاعب موظف الحكومي ولا غير
موظف الحكومي اما يفوت على مستشفى اذا
اصابع شيء
يعني احنا بنحكي عن النظام هذا الاستبداد
لم يحدث حتى في القران الوسطى حتى اذكرون
الوسطى لما بنستحضر التاريخ وانا
بالمناسبه استاذ استاذ همم حضاره حضاره
عربيه حتى بالقرون الوسطى لم تشهد الشعوب
وحركه الشعوب من هذا النوع من الاستبداد
المقاونا استبداد طائفي بياخذوا له احجام
واشكال وهو مطاطي بالسرير يلعب ويتبادى مع
الازمات
لامتصاص خيرات الشعوب وذبح الشعوب وتكوين
الشعوب جميل جدا دكتور كيف ترد على هذا رد
لي على هذه النقطه بدون ما تروح لي على
الشعوب الان هل تستطيع لا تستطيع ان ترد
لا لا لا
لا كيف يعني الدكتور ربما انه اقدر انه
جاء من منطقه يعني منزلقه
[موسيقى]
حتى عندما نقول ان هذه الدول لم تتمكن من
التفاهم مع المؤسسات الدوليه وهو في
المقدمه ده لهذا غير صحيح يعني مصر بالفعل
وقعت اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي برغم
انه يجبرها على ان تخصص الشركات الخاضعه
للمؤسسات السياديه هو للجيش تونس بالتاكيد
مضت وقاعد بالفعل قد اتفاق مع صندوق النقد
الدولي كذلك تونس همم السودان في ظل ظروفه
وقع اتفاق مع صندوق الدولي
نحن نقول ان اذا كانت هذه الانظمه الفاسده
لا تريد ولا تستطيع ان تصل الى معايير ي-
يتراها المؤسسه الدوليه ك- كفئه لا هناك
ثلاثه دول تحدثنا عنها وصلت بالفعل الى
مستوى الكفاء لكن هذا لا يمنع ان هناك لا
يعني ارضك همم المؤسسات الدوليه
لكن على الاقل هي من وجهه نظر المؤسسه
الدوليه تمتلك القدر الادنى من الكفاء
وتستطيع ان ترفع كفاءتها بما يحقق المصالح
نعود الى موضوع همم العمله تخفيض العمله
العمله ربما ان بعض الدول مثل تونس لا
تملك هيكل الانتاج لكنها تملك السياحه
وعاشت لقرون مزدهره وكبيره جدا من اجل
السياحه حتى لبنان نفسه لبنان كانت خزان
خزان خزائنه تمتلئ من السياحه ومن وجود
الفعليات فعندما تخفض قيمه العمله انا
طبعا لا اتحدث عن ما حدث من مؤامره على
لبنان وربما يعني تسمح لنا ظروف لنتحدث
كيف وصل للبنان الى هذه الحاله وانت تعلم
انني يعني كم حزين على ما وصل اليه وكان
كتبته في هذا المجال لكن لن نقول انه حتى
ان لم يكن الدول تمتلك هيكل انتاج قوي
فهنا لك الدعوه مثل همم تونس مثل لبنان
تمتلك مقومات سياحيه كانت تحقق لها مدخولا
كبيرا وكانت تحقق لها ولكن ما هي المشكله
همم
على سبيل الخصوص يعني مقاسات لبنان كان في
موقعها الجغرافي يعني يعلم الجميع ان هنا
قالوا للبنان اما اما الانصياع الكامل
واما العوده الى العصر الحجري هكذا قالوها
ولما هو سبب يعني همم يعني انا اسف اني
اتكلم عن لبنان في وجود دكتور لكن
المرفق يعني تدمير المرفا كان مجرد
الرساله يا دكتور تتخيل هذه الكارثه التي
يعني حطمت افضل الاماكن الموجوده في لبنان
واعاده لبنان ويعني حطمت صوامع الغلال
ومحطات الكهرباء تخيل كانت مجرد الرساله
فقط
ان لم ت- يعني تنفذ اوامرنا فهذه احدى
العينات مما سوف ترونها ماذا يمكن ان يفعل
صحيح سوريا همم سوريا سوريا سوريا سوريا
يعني
غير سوريا سوريا
في لبنان لا كانت القبضه الصهيونيه قاتله
طيب قاتله كيف ترد على هذا الكلام كلام مش
صحيح
الصهاينه الاسرائيليين طيب لماذا كل قوى
المقاومه اليوم منعت التحقيق في اللي في
لبنان حتى نعرف الصهاينه اللي فجر المراه
مظبوط ولا لا ليش مانعوه
صار في معارك واشتباكات في محيط عين
الرمانه
وقسم القضاء ونحو اول قاضي ثاني قاضي هي
هذه القوى فلتتفضل تترك التحقيق هياخذ
مجروح وتقول انه اسرائيل هي التي تفجرتنا
انا مش انا دافع عن حدانا بس كفى تحججا
والتعليق على حبل فلسطين التعليق على حبل
فلسطين صار مدمر الشعوب هذه الناس وهذه
بتقع من الحاكمه عم بتعلق على حامل فلسطين
من اجل الاستباحه الناس وكرامه الناس وكل
الناس هذا هو اللي عن بصير بعدين بدنا
نطلع احنا بنقصر المؤامرات الخارجيه ما
احد فاضي
العرب
بس بدنا نطلع من قضيه المؤامرات بالسباحه
الشعوب اتفضل عندك راي اقتصادي عندك نظريه
اقتصاديه نفذ هذه الكهرباء للناس وعندك
انت اسئله واستفهامات حاول تفجير المرفقه
الوزراء المتورطين الاستدعاهم القاضي
القاضي التح خليهم يروحوا ان يعملوا معارك
عسكريه بقلب بيروت حتى ما يروح ال ال ال
ال النواب والوزراء المحسوبين عليهم خليه
يروحوا يقولوا انه اي فعلا هو الصهيوني
الذي فجر مرفا بيروت الصهيوني الذي دمر
لبنان الصهيوني الذي فعل كل كذا انا لا
ابرء ان الصهيوني لديه مشروع ومشاريع هو
عم يتحفظ على لبنان بس انتم امنتوا له هذه
التغطيه الداخليه هذا الانقسام الداخلي
الطائفي هذا الجوع عند الناس لما تجوع
ولما بتمشي بالقران ما في اصلاحات وما في
مستقبل اولادها ما في يعني شو مطلوب من
الناس بعد ما فينا بعد
خارجيه
وامريكا والشيطان الاكبر والشيطان الاكبر
انت باميرك اعطيته كل النفط والغاز وانت
خليت على خط 29 في لبنان شو هالكلام هذا
2290 كيلو متر مربع طول الاسرائيلي
بعد نحكي بالمؤامرات تفضل يا دكتور المرفق
قلنا لبنان
كان الرساله طيب لو بدات التحقيقات في
السير لا احد يعلم مات حجم الرساله التي
سوف تكون في المرحله التاليه تمام تمام
على مدار الاسبوع على مدار الاسبوع لماذا
ينهار الدينار العراقي والعراق ثاني اغنى
بلد في النفط بالعالم العراق لديه ميزانيه
سنويا تزيد على 140 مليار دولار ليس عنده
كهرباء ليس عنده كهرباء اكثر من مره
ميزانيه الكهرباء وكانت اكثر من 30 مليار
دولار تبخرت لا احد يعرف ليس له كهرباء
الناس لا تجد حتى البنزين بلد يعوم على
على بحر من النفط وليس هناك بنزين وليس
هناك كود و و و والناس تموت من الجوع وكذا
طيب لماذا تنهار العمله في العراق في
العراق على وجه الخصوص هناك الاقتتال
الطائفي والمصالح الطائفيه يعني حضرتك
بتقول ان العائدات عائدات النفط الثانويه
الثانويه تجعل المواطن العراقي من اغلى ال
ال ال الاغبياء
الجزء من المصالح الموجوده ما بين الطوائف
ان لذلك قلت ان في لبنان وفي العراق
المساله طائفيه
في طائفيه
في سوريا في دقيقه دقيقه في سوريا يا
دكتور ليش عم تهرب من الموضوع شو دخل
الطوائف
في العراق
يدخل الى الخزانه العراقيه يعني هذا لا
مجال عندما نتحدث عن 100 مليار دولار يعني
80 مليار دولار ثم نقول انه هو ال- ال-
البند الوحيد في الصادرات في الصادرات حتى
هذا انت مع الدكتور انه انت يا دكتور انت
بدات بالكلام انه خارجي وما خارجي لا انت
ركز لي عليها مشان ما نضيع
لا لا
من شان ما نضيع تمام
انا سالتك الان عن العراق انا اتي الك الى
اتي بك الى سوريا سوريا يا سيدي لا اختلف
معك مرت بسنوات من الحرب والتدمير المنهج
و و و و و يا سيدي سوريا الان سوريا الان
النظام النظام الساكن في القصر الجمهوري
تحول الى عصابه تعفيش وتكويش نتحدث الان
البنك المركزي السوري لماذا تنهار الليره
البنك المركزي السوري ليس فيه دولار واحد
ليس فيه دولار واحد حتى
حتى المساعدات الدوليه التي تاتي لتوزع
على المحتاجين داخل سوريا
يتاجر بها النظام ويبيعها بالسوق السوداء
قبل ايام قبل يومين ايران رفعت اسعار
النفط الذي تورته الى سوريا الى مستويات
عاليه لماذا لماذا هل تعلم لماذا
تصدره الى سوريا يبيعه راس النظام السوري
وزوجته والعصابه في السوق السوداء كل
مصافي النفط في سوريا كل ما صافي النفط
تشتغل لصالح عصابه الناس لا تجد البنزين
لا تجد الوقود تموت من الجوع تموت من
البرد لا تجد اي شيء والعمله السوريه
تنهار على مدار الساعه لماذا لماذا لانه
هناك عصابه
تتحكم تتاجر بالبلد حولت البلد الى بزنس
يا دكتور يا دكتور بدي اسالك هل تعلم انهم
انهم يقتحمون
كل المؤسسات الاقتصاديه في سوريا
والكاسيات كل مكان فيه فلوس
يقتحمون هذه الاماكن ويصادرون الاموال
الناس وارزاق الناس وكذا ماذا ستفعل رؤوس
الاموال في سوريا كلها هربت كلها هربت
انهيار العمله في سوريا انهيار العمله في
مصر انهيار العمله في السودان انهيار
العمله في تونس انهيار العمله في اليمن
نفس القصه نفس اللعبه ليش عم بتلف وتدور
خلينا نتفق يعني زي واخد من كلام حضرتك
قلت ان ايران اكتشفت ان النفط الذي تعطيه
للسوريين يتاجر النبي لولا وجود هذا
الشريان لا ذهب ولا نظام السوري ووقع ايضا
في نفس الشيء في
العراقيه لهذه العصابات لو وقعت هذا
النظام الطائفي
الصهيونيه بكل مقاومتها على الحدود
اللبنانيه وتهدد كل من يحاول ان يتخذ خطوه
سلامه في اتجاه بناء النظام اللبناني
وعودته مره اخرى لا زابولت هذه الطائفيه
وانتهت لقائمه الشعوب لقائمه الشعوب يعني
هناك كانت هناك حركات حقيقيه من قبل
الشعوب من اجل استعاده ما يحدث يعني يعني
انهيار العملات وراء امريكا
واسرائيل بالتاكيد بالتاكيد بالتاكيد يعني
عندما نتحدث عن يعني لا اريد ان نعود الى
لكن لا ناخذ لناخذ مثال من همم العراق
النسبه الغالبه من المدخول العراقي نتيجه
تصدير النفط الذي يحدده الامريكان تذهب
الى الخزانه الخزانه همم العراقيه لكنها
لا توزع على مشاريع عراقيه حيث يتم تسديد
ديون الحرب ال- ال- حرب الخليج الاولى
والثانيه والتي وضعت امريكا همم قيمه
عاليه جدا لعده سنوات سوف تتبعها يدفع
يدفعها الاقتصاد العراقي سواء بقى كان
الشعب
اطلقني مشروع اخراج الامريكي من العراق
نعود الى نعود الى السودان الى السودان
على سبيل المثال دوله المشاكل التي تحدث
يوميا ولمده عامين من من اضطرابات ومشاكل
كيف سيتمكن اي نظام من العمل في ظل عدم
وجود استقرار يعني حتى عندما تتحدث عن
امكانيه همم في سوريا طيب ماشي ماشي في
سوريا
دكتور بيتحدث عن الاحتياطات الدوليه مصر
حتى الان لديها 33 مليار دولار 33 مليار
دولار الاحتياطي النقدي القانوني طبقا
للمعايير العربيه همم العالميه المطلوب
يجب ان يغطي في حدود ثلاث اشهر واردات اين
تحدث في حدود 24 مليار دولار اي ان
الاقتصاد المصري بيمتلك 9 مليار دولار
يستطيع ان يناور بها في السوق الصرف
والحفاظ على استقرار سعر الصرف الجنيه
المصري لكن كما قلت لحضرتك للاسف الشديد
اثناء مفاوضاتهم مع صندوق النقد الدولي
تمت وضع الروشته التي يتضعف صندوق النقد
الدولي بالسياره وهي تخفيض قيمه العمله من
اجل رفع تنفسيه الاقتصاد الاشكاليه في هذه
الجزئيه يعني انت تقول للمصريين يا جماعه
احملوا نحن الزهر
لا لا لا يعني نقول ان الاداره المصريه
لديها من المقومات والموارد ما تستطيع به
الحفاظ على استقرار قيمه الجيش
اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي حتى حتى لا
تصدر التقارير التي تحدثت من خلال العام
الماضي عن احتماليه الاقتصاد المصري نقطه
مهمه جدا همم
يريدون ان تظل المؤشرات الاقتصاديه في مصر
مرتفعه بالمقارنه بالمؤسلات حتى وان كان
ذلك تجويع الناس وهذه للاسف هي سياسه
خاطئه لكن يعتقدون كما تفضلت حضرتك بان
اذا احتملنا عام 1 الحكم يعني نظام الحكم
عام واحد وتبقى لكل التقرير الاقتصاديه
وحتى الصندوق النقد الدولي نفسه يعني رفع
بعد التوقيع توقعاته لنمو الانسان المصري
من اربعه فاصل اربعه الى 6.6 بمجرد
التوقيع بمفرده التوقيع يا دكتور انت تعلم
لم يدخل بلد او لم تدخل دوله الى غرفه
انعاش صندوق النقد الدولي وكان طلعت منه
طلعت منه الانعاش
بالراحه لكن يعطي واحد ههه
راح بلش من العراق العراق
بنظام حكم توافقي مش نظام حكم ديمقراطيه
يعني ممنوع اي قرار بمجلس الوزراء يؤخذ
وبدون ما توافق عليه كل الطوائف وكل همم
ارادات العراق الموجود اليوم هي مش عم
تروح للخزينه يعني في اربيل وفي
الميليشيات كمان الى حصه متهرب
ايضا في ذات الطوافق وزيت السيما الطائفي
والمذابي اللي ما بيقدروا يحلوا يعني حاول
تسبيله يشيلوها من هون في لبنان اذا
انتقلنا الى تونس وانت تقول انه تونس يعني
هاي اللعبه للطائفه ولا شيء ما هيك طيب
تونس كيف بقيتي رئيس بيحل المحكمه العليا
ومجلس النواب والحكومي والدستور والنقابات
وحل مجلس الوزراء ما خلى شيء الا محله كيف
قادر انه يحكم كيف قادر المستثمر ان ياتي
الى تونس كيف لا يمكن ان تنهار دينار تونس
حلو ايوه
بهذا الموضوع ما في نظام حكم شرعي قائم
على مؤسسات دستوريه حبيبي لهذه الدول ما
في شرعيه ولا مؤسسات دستوريه لحتى
المستثمر ياتي من هذه الدوله ويضع
استثماراته لحتى من العمله الصعبه لحتى
بالنهايه تكون العمر شويه باريحيه ايضا عن
مشروعات القوميه في مصر حتى نقول كمان قلت
قلت
المشروعات والصرف المشروعات على المشروعات
القوميه همم الضخمه ومن دون الالتفات الى
اولويات الشعب
رغد واللوات وراء البنك الدولي البنك
الدولي بيعطيك مسكنات بيعطيك علاجات 7-8
مليار دولار بتصرفها ريوع لتسكيت الناس من
جوعها ومن ثم نعود الى الاستدانه من جديد
الاحتياطات النقديه اليوم الديون الخارجيه
المصريه 177 مليون دولار ليش ما قلتها يا
دكتور
حجز الموازنه 14 مليار دولار لما بيكون
فيه بالدولي مثل مصر فيها قناه السويس
وفيها غاز وفيها نفط عم متصدر ليش بده
يكون عجز الميزانيه فيها 14 مليار دولار
احنا بنفهم لبنان عم تحكموا الطائفيه
العراق كذلك سوريا كذلك بس مصر دوله قويه
على هذا المستوى فاذا هناك السوء في اداره
الاقتصاد والاداء الاقتصاد
كل المؤسسات الجيش بالمناسبه كله على
التنافسيه على المستوى التجاري لان الجيش
صار يعني هو العنوان الكبير في كل
الاستثمارات في مصر وفي كل حركه التجاره
وصار يملك الارض تعرف انه انت بقانون سنه
1900 وهذا ما بدي انا اقول لك
1997 يا اللي شرع للجيش بيقول انه يحط يده
على كل الاراضي او المصريه الغير مستثمره
والغير واللي ما فيها هذا قانون السباحه
بشكل كامل طيب لماذا هذا التكبير من حجم
وقوه الجيش لان الجيش بيستفيدوا منه عبر
التجنيد الاجباري بالعمل مجانا هل هكذا
تبنى الدول
نحنا بعد ما نعيش بعصر فراعنه مستقبل
العملات على ضوء ذلك ماذا هو لا هذه الدول
اذا ما استمرت في هذا على هذا المنوال اذا
ما استمر ستذهب الى التقصين حكم ستذهب الى
التقصير طيب السودان ايضا السودان اللي هو
يعتبر سله همم الغذاء اليوم فقدت العمله
السودانيه 89% من قيمتها ثلاث سنوات
لبنان 95 سوريا 99 خذ لك دول يعني ترفع
شعارات اليمن لانه في سؤال
في سؤال في عمل ثاني يعني لما الناس بتحكي
اصلا في لانه ما في بيانات ما حدا بقدر
اجيب اصلا بيانات من لا بسوريا ولا باليمن
بالمناسبه لانه ما حدا بيقدر يفوت لا
مؤسسه الشفافيه الدوليه ولا احد بيقدري
يعني يعرف قيمه العملات ويشوف حركه همم
يعني حركه الاقتصاد بس هذه الدول اللي
اليوم عم ترفع شعارات البناء والتجهيز
القومي ومش بس عم نحكي احنا بكل هذه الدول
اللي هم عملتها ساقطه لانه ما في اداره ما
عندهم تفكير وانا عنده نظريات اقتصاديه
بيقدروا ان الجيش البلد هل الامريكي اجى
على سوريا او على العراق وعلى لبنان وقال
لهم ما تعملوا معامل الكهرباء ليه معامل
الكهرباء مين معي بس انت السمسارات
والفساد والسيئه
بلبنان اتكلم اتكلم
45 مليار دولار 45 مليار دولار سرقه ونهبا
واليوم ما في لمبه لبنان وفي سوريا في
سوريا سوريا
52 و32 ما في مكيفات
مش حرام عليكم هذه الشعوب تعيش بهذه
الظلاميه ايضا في سوريا شو هي السياسات
الاقتصاديه التي
وقفت الحرب وقلنا انه انتصرنا على
الميليشيات وعلى الاحزاب وعلى الارهاب
وعلى الارهاب وعلى اللي بدك اياه وين
السياسيات الاقتصاديه اللي عندك في سياسات
اقتصاديه ما الذي يحدث في سوريا بين
السياسات اقتصاديه انت ماذا كيف تراها
الان يعني اصلا
سوريا مقابل الدولار حوالي 7000 صحيح
20,000$
صحيح
في في سوريا هل هناك سياسات اقتصاديه ام
فقط فساد ياكل الجميع والراس الفساد هو
راس النظام ما هو اضعاف الدوله
للمؤسسات الامنيه ولا المؤسسات الاقتصاديه
ولا المؤسسات التشريعيه ما حدا عم بيقوم
بدوره ولما بيقعد فيه دور لهذه المؤسسات
المتفككه حكما ستستبيحه الميليشيات
الموجوده
صعبه هي الحكمه التي ستسترد وسيكون لها
الباعه يعني مجموعه من المنتخب
ان يعني يجب ان بعين الاعتبار ما حدث لتلك
البلدان على مدى ال 10 سنوات الماضيه بما
فيها مصر مصر سودان العراق لبنان اليمن
سوريا
يا سيدي
التحولات او سمه الانتفاضات دمرت كل شيء
ليش تدمر الدقيقه لم يعد هناك يا دكتور لم
يعد هناك انتاج اه كل قطاعات الانتاج
توقفت الانتاج الصناعي السياحي الزراعي
مثلا في سوريا يعني حبيت خاف الله ونكرهت
خاف الله في سوريا لم يبقى هناك اي قطاع
يعمل في سوريا لهذا ستنهار الليره لهذا
يعني مش كله النظام مش كله النظام وكله
الفساد
ما تستطيع ذلك سوريا
حلفاء او تحالفاتها كان مع الايراني وان
كان مع الروسي فينا ننقل هذا الشيء اين هو
الايراني والروس اليوم خليه يضوي شعشع
الكهرباء في سوريا ليش ما عنده كهرباء
لانه مصلحته الوضع على مهاره حاليا
بالعماله ما حدا بقى يحكي هاي الشعوب هذه
الدول انت عم تقول انه هذه الدوله هي تدفع
ضريبه وقوفها الى جانب المحور المقاتل
المدري شو المدري شو ضد الامريكي طب هذا
المحور عم تقول له عم الشيخ هلا اوكرانيا
خليه يعطيك بواخر نفس
شويه فلوس
هل تعلم هذا الحديث الروسي هو الذي ذهب
البنك المركزي في سوريا
هذه الدول مع ذلك بتقول لك انا اتصلت على
المشروع الامريكي انتصرت كيف باقول لك انا
انتصرت على المشروع الاسرائيلي انت كيف
انتصر لما منتصر
النصبيه انا بالعالم عم بحكي لما انا
بنتصل على المشروع الاسرائيلي يعني انا ما
تجيب الاسرائيلي بابنهضيها على شروط هذه
شروط هذه تاك
اعطاء الفلسطينيين وارجاعهم الى فلسطين
مضبوط حق العوده همم الضفه الغربيه منع
المستوطنات يعني كل هاي شروط المنتصر على
الاسرائيليه لا زالت الى يهمني بيقولوا ان
احنا منتصرون واسرائيل بتطلع بتفلح من غزه
الى اليمن
طيب انا بدي اسالك عن المساعدات الدوليه
والمساعدات الخليجيه لكل دول العربيه
كثيره ضخها مليارات الدولارات احيانا اكثر
من 40 50 مليار دولار في اكثر من في اكثر
من مكان اين تبخرت هذه المليارات كم منها
دخل الى الميزانيات او الى خزائن هذه
الدول العربيه سوريا مصر السودان اليمن
ليبيا همم جزائر كله كله حقيقه دقيقه هذه
بلدان تحولت الى ثقوب سوداء ما هم ما
جاءها من مليارات ستختفي هذه المليارات يا
سيدي البعض يقول لك لو ان حكام تلك الدول
اتوا ب 10% من ملياراتهم المودعه في
الخارج قعدوها الى البنوك المركزيه كما في
سوريا لن تعشت العمله الليره السوريه
بسرعه وانتعشت كم مليار دولار لبناني
موجود خارج لبنان لو عاد قسمه منها لو عاد
قسمه منها
دقيقه ماذا ماذا سيحدث لليره اللبنانيه
فيما لو عاد جزء بسيط من هذه المليارات هل
تنتعش ولا ما
تنفع لو المليارات التي موجوده في خزائن
في حسابات الانظمه في سوريا في مصر في
السودان في لبنان في العراق في كذا لو
عادت المليارات الموهوبه من العراق لماذا
لماذا لا نتحدث عن المليارات المنهوبه
التي
تدمر العملات المحليه شيئا فشيئا انهاب
والسرقه والفساد واللصوصيه يا رجل
ملياراتنا اصبحت كل خارج البلاد بانها من
هو دكتور
ههه
جزء مهم ماذا حدثت فيه عن ال ال ال ال
المساعدات وهو نفس النقطه التي تحدث فيها
الدكتور رايد عن الحلفاء ما تم ضخه في كل
هذه الاقتصادات كان بحساب ومعلوم هو كانت
همم
وكان هناك علم مؤكد ان هذه المليارات لن
تستخدم للتنميه لانها اذا استخدمت في
التنميه سوف تعود قوه هذه الدول ولا في
اعتقادي
ولا يوجد الكثيرين مما يريدون عوده سوريا
اكمل يعني عوده سوريا الى وضعها او عوده
لبنان الى ان يكون حضاره العالم او عوده
مصر الى القوه الاقليميه الكبيره مؤمن ومن
هنا ومن هنا
تمام الدكتور رائد فقط ومن هنا كانت كل
هذه المساعدات وكل هذه الاموال كانت
بالفعل يعلم من يقدمها انها لن تذهب
للتنميه بل سوف تزيد الفاسدين وسوف تؤدي
الى اتساع رقعه
الدكتور الدكتور رائد يقول انهم بالاساس
فسد انا اقول لا بالعكس هم هيات لهم وسائل
الفساد ثم نحكي على جزء مهم جدا من الحلقه
كنا نتمنى ان التحدث عندما نتحدث عن
الشعوب التي تجوع ولا تعلم من اين سوف
تاكل لماذا لا تتحرك هذه الشعور لماذا لا
تتحرك تشعر خليك شويه دكتور دكتور هذا
سؤال جوهري طيب نحن لماذا نضع كل المشاكل
على هذه الانظمه الفاسده اللصه الحراميه
كذا كذا كذا كذا طيب الان ماذا ستاكل
الشعوب العربيه ماذا ستاكل انا بدي اسالك
سؤال لبنان انها تموت من الجوع وتعيش على
السله الغذائيه في سوريا اما تهرب
الان عم بيتدفعوا على على على على ملابسهم
يحرقون ملابسهم في مصر بيطلعوا بيعملوا
تيك توك وبيعملوا كذا في السودان نفس
العمليه يا اخ فيصل عملنا حلقه عن الفساد
في السودان طيب وبعدين يا ايتها الشعوب
بعدين هذا هو سؤال بدي اسالك اياه الشعوب
الى اين عندما قامت الشعوب الانفيه
باختصار
2011 بهذه الثورات من اجل التغيير اصطدمت
يعني كان في رديت فعل على عليها من قبل
الجيش يعني من قبل الجيوش الجيش حطوه
بالمواجهه لانه بيعرفوا دائما بكل الدول
الجيوش لها يعني وجدان عندها الشعوب
فبطبيعه الحال هي استولت على هذا الموضوع
حولت كل اراء الشعوب والضغطها من اجل منعه
من التغيير دليل مصر وتونس وحتى في لبنان
في جزء اساسي من البلدان التي ارادت
شعوبها التغيير اليوم نحن امام اختمار
يعني هذه الشعوب هي تتمر وتتحضر
الانقلابات حقيقيه لان استفادت من تجارب
السابقه يعني
بدها تطيح فيهم يعني بدهم يعني
كل الدول
نصف الشعب اكثر لا خمير الحمر او الحمير
الحمر اللي بدك اياها سميه الخمير طبعا بس
حمير قتلوا خمسه ملايين ولم يتغير شيء
موتسونغ قتل 80 مليون لينين واستالين قتله
عشرات الملايين افريقيا كذا يا سيدي
الشعوب لن تفعل شيئا سيموتوننا للجوع فاذا
هذه الشعوب
فلتاكل من ما تيسر
الام الناس وان تلجا الى التغيير وان تلجا
الى المحاسبه وهذا العمل بده عمل تراكمي
كبير جدا على باختصار الكلمه الاخيره
اربعه يقول ان هذا ما نحشده الان من
انهيار للعملات اوضاع معيشيه كارثيه
الشعوب تموت من الجوع والبرد وكذا وكذا في
العديد من الدول هو سببه الثورات المضاده
الثورات المضاده نجحت في اعاده الشعوب الى
زريبه الطاعه اه لكنها لم تنجح في تامين
ابسط مستلزمات الشعوب الخبز الاقتصاديات
في تونس في تونس قديش صلوا هذا قيس السعيد
هل يعقل انه راعي ابل او ما بعرف شو هو
يدير الاقتصاد السوداني يا زلمه
عندما تاتي بشخص مثل هذا هو استاذ اكاديمي
هو المفترض ان لديه جزء من الوعي وليس له
تاريخ ليس له تاريخ اما في حمل السلاح ولا
في المشاكل ربما في السودان عندما تتحدث
عن راعي الابل هو يملك السلاح ويملك
الميليشيا ويستطيع الامر
في هذه في الانظمه دقيقه دقيقه انا بدي
اسالك الان بدي اسالك الى اين الان بعد
هذه المشاعات وبعدها انهيار العملات الى
اين انت انت الان متفائل الى اين لا لا
بالطريق الرجل
حتى حتى من سجنوا وقتل اولادهم عندما
يتحدثون عن احتمال ان تكون هناك ثوره جياع
يقولون لا لن نقبل ان نعود لعدم الامان
الذي مرضنا بها في السنوات الماضيه حتى من
ظلموا وسجنه وقتل ابناؤهم طيب
باختصار ان هذه الانظمه كما تمكنت من
اعاده الشعوب الى الحظائر فهي ملزمه ان
تعلفها حتى لا تموت هذه الشعوب ومن هنا
انا في اعتقادي ان الخمس سنوات القادمه
يعني نتحدث بعد ان تنتهي ازمه كورونا»
الازمه الاخرانيه لا لا اعتقد انه سوف
يكون هناك نسبه تحسن على الاقل على الاقل
في كل الدول العربيه التي تعاني من
المشاكل تكرر لك العباره الشعبيه الشهيره
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب والدكتور
رائد المصري نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل
فحتى ذلك هنا هو فيصل القاسم يحييكم الى
الدوحه
[موسيقى]